he is Jabril peppers of the Cleveland
Browns how if you bend your brill am i
I'm doing better for talking to you I'm
doing better so first question for you
are they are the Hard Knocks cameras on
you right now
talking to me it's actually not as bad
as they may think well I mean it's good
right I don't sit bad I mean it's good
to get a camera on you're right you
could shine out you get everybody know
who you are yeah but I you know I had a
lot of people ask me like uh you know
you don't like all those cameras in your
face how do you guys who knows you gotta
watch to say since cameras only 24/7 you
know it's like the cameras the cameras
are there but you know it's always
cameras at practice you know it's just
now that they're in a meeting room
sometimes and then other times you know
when you're just so locked in you don't
even really notice it but you know it's
definitely is definitely cool you know
to you know give the people but look at
you know what we're doing and you know
how Achon to understand all right okay
so let's talk about turning this thing
around how would you rate your rookie
season no no just give me a word for
your rookie season boy how would you
rate it
um I'll price a below average so what
happens there oh I just didn't make the
play you know that I normally make that
I expect myself to make and you know I
feel as though if I make those plays you
know in some of those games you know we
may win one or two games you know what I
mean so you know that's why that's why I
say that so how will things be different
this year and your belief how are you a
different player talking to me right now
than how do I've been on the phone last
year to your to your to from year one
that night day you know as far as you
know the understanding the playbook
that's the first and foremost you know
now not only do I understand what I have
to do I understand what everyone has to
do and I've played multiple positions in
the distance already which allows me to
play sighs during play towards my help
you know when I can
you know them got a chance to be around
you know some great veterans you know
learn how to actually watch film in the
right way learn how to actually know go
about being a pro you know cuz you know
when you when you come out you know
we've been playing the game since we're
about four or five years old you know
you do you think that you know you kind
of got it all figured out I mean again
when you go through something like I
went through last year you just got to
kind of step back and evaluate and you
know look at yourself in the mirror and
put down what you could have done better
where you could have done more and if
there's anything that you feel like you
could have done better or done more then
you're already lost you know cause
you're supposed to be leaving it out
there anyway you know what I mean so for
me it's just understanding that a
playbook actually knowing knowing the
guys in the league knowing knowing how
certain guys play serve guys strength
you know how certain coordinators coach
you know who's who's from that that that
coaching tree of coordinators there
probably has certain similarities
you know just it's just a lot of things
that I did know as a rookie coming out
that I know now going into you know my
second year so look out are you one of
those players right now on the defense
that's hitting the quarterback the Todd
Haley's complaining about Gregg Williams
is saying then block them are you one of
them that was me that I'll cut it close
I cut it close to cover style and
working on that okay okay are the
coordinators getting along right now
gibreel it seems yeah okay absolutely
you know it's competition you know Cote
is a competitive god bless those clothes
Louis you know we need that you know
that makes that makes the players want
to compete against each other that much
harder you know what I mean so is this
it's it's all funny love man it's all
okay cuz we're see and it just seems
like sometimes that they're barking at
each other and they're two alpha male
they're not gonna back down
they're not gonna back down competition
is good very buddy my bet I bet and in
terms of the competition at quarterback
is there one because it just seems
everyone's saying it's tie rods job is
it his job despite Baker being there I
mean everything is a competition this
competition is and every wrong you know
and I think that's how you
the best out of you know one another you
know when you when you got to compete
against a guy with like talent and you
know things like that and it's in every
room you know what I mean so no one
knows until that first game you know
what I mean but they both look good both
doing things extremely well you know to
rise the veteran you know the approving
that takes care of the ball took took
the bill to the playoffs you know what I
mean and you know Baker has shown that
he can't play in this be strong on very
accurate bill mechanics good pocket
presidents you know and I and it
surprised me because a lot of people
thought of him as a you know scrambling
quarterback you know and I think I don't
know this but this is what I think from
you know just practicing against them
that he's trying to force himself to
stay in the pocket and go through his
progression before he you know uses his
legs so you know that show me that he's
China you know really work on the things
that he needs to work on you know to to
to be a starter initially and Tyrod the
purple guy to help him do it you know
and it and like what I say it's all
competition it's good competition it's
not one guy secretly hoping the other
guy does back you know it's you know
let's let's compete and make each other
better
but whatever you don't know you know
this is why I'm ready to help to
pronounce answer
I think that's dope Jabril peppers Brown
safety here on the Rich Eisen show have
you talked with Baker about planting
that flag in the middle of the horseshoe
against Omaha state ah no I love it
though man I love it you know you sure
did then I could I couldn't had a chance
to do I know I love it I know so how
tough is it for you to be in state of
Ohio Jabril I mean among a lot man like
you know I didn't think it would be you
know as flagrant as it was as far as you
know that Ohio State fans and you know
things like that cuz at the end of the
day you know I'm with Cleveland Brown
now and my only goal is to you know when
ballgame course but you know you'd be
making a ton of Ohio State fans happy in
the process to with your football play
yeah
right yeah I only really think about
them so many more no they they come to
practice scream out scream out my name
you know I think it's because they want
me to say allocated to the child or so
okay
all right right way come on man so they
they are doing it they do bring up the
Michigan thing despite trying to get you
over to hang out with them is that what
you're saying
that actually happens yeah that's right
is it tough but at the end of the day I
do want to ask you this too bro you know
you were as a freshman DJ Durkin was
your defensive coordinator and yeah I'm
sure you're reading what's going on in
Maryland did you exhibit did he exhibit
any of the tactics that are being
alleged to have been made in in football
in Maryland right now Jabril I mean
coach Dirk he was a different a
different guy you know what I mean but
you know his his tactics were different
you know I saw extreme at times but you
know I'm just in shock you know reading
the reading the reading all the other
stuff that's going on now because I
thought you know he was only like that
because they know it was his first time
you know coaching us he's a defensive
coordinator I you know so he was just
trying to get us to buy into how he
wants his decent to play and I thought
you know once he became a head coach you
know that he will you know calm down a
little bit
become more of a know a people person in
a player's coach but I wasn't really
following him you know once he left you
know because you know a couple a couple
of the guys including myself he didn't
like how everything went down you know
when he left but I'm just as shocked as
you know read reading the stuff that I'm
saying it work can you give me an
example of the extreme that you exist
that you witnessed or were went through
in a way
Jabril oh no this is the way
you know that he he goes about getting
the most out of his players you know me
you know being from where I from when
I'm from you know I didn't like it but
at the end of the day I knew what the
overall goal was you know what I mean
but you know just know the way I would
describe it um you know it's kind of
like bully coaching you know what I mean
oh I don't think he meant anything by it
but you know it just it just kind of how
it foams up a couple more minutes here
with Jabril peppers Brown safety here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so when it all
comes down to it how many wins give me
some give me a win total for the Browns
this year what do you think Jabril man
I'm not in the predicting business but I
can assure you that he was never have
another year like last year
not again week one taking on the
Steelers what's that gonna be like walk
me through what you think you're gonna
happen they're gonna be good at home
which is a game I thought we should have
won you know we had a block kick early
on in the game that that really hurt us
because we ended up losing about four
points so you know and it's it's a lot
of games last year where we were right
there in the game or you know lost by
touchdown or less you know what I mean
that we just have to execute better and
you're not feel as though with you know
the veterans we have in the room now and
you know the SEC of your players
actually you understand what you know
the coaches are at know what their
schemes and things like that you know I
definitely think there's gonna be a
positive and then the week before that
week one Michigan Notre Dame what are
you hearing about this kid the
quarterback
what are hearing about Patterson coming
out of Ann Arbor one of the words you're
hearing about oh yeah I'm Jabril know I
remember him when he was down in the SEC
me you know a really good core
back have you really been you know
hearing much lately you know because
I've been you know trying to get myself
right for the season as well but uh you
know it's gonna be some it's gonna be
competition over there - I don't know
they they're now say he's starting it
well I'm sure I'm sure Harbaugh is
keeping that close to the vest for yeah
reasons but that that kid better stroll
on the Indiana a couple weekends I'll
tell you that right now I'm told I mean
so it is definitely gonna be you know
some competition and I don't know how
good the the other freshman is number
five know the quarterback is not sure
that's your number Jabril he better be
good yeah like whoever is whoever they
start you know yes it has going through
the proper procedures and protocol could
be able to be called the starter you
know is gonna put their best foot
forward how's that - well great chatting
with you here Jabril you know last time
I saw your face to face cuz I didn't get
to see at the combine it was on the
field after uh the the game where I was
the honorary captain where you you ran
through a brick wall because of my words
couple days before right that's right
yeah so and I'm the one in the
photograph for showing right now that
doesn't look swell so you know I'm the
one on the left
we're showing that photograph right now
we were chatting after the game so it's
it's just great to see it the next level
Jabril and I hope you have a great
season yes I appreciate it you got it
you take care of that Jabril peppers
Brown safety the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience